I've really gotten into piano.
I just love it.
Especially Beethoven,
I play Beethoven every night
on my Discord server.
Just like 20 people show up,
but I just play through the sonatas
over and over.
It just makes me feel incredible.
Doesn't matter what
happened during the day,
I just feel great.
And what is it about Beethoven?
I love that I'm acting like
"this Beethoven guy,"
but specifically,
what is it about his music
that's getting you right now?
Oh, I've always loved it.
Right.
Since I was a teenager,
but now I can semi-play it.
So that's-
Yeah.
It's just, I don't know.
He's like-
It's just how my brain works.
He just gets my attention
and he keeps it
and takes me to all these different places
and it's such an emotional ride.
Put on Mozart and I space out
after five seconds.
Can't get into it.
Right.
So, Tim,
you mentioned that
now it's about piano for you.
Are you teaching yourself?
Do you have a tutor?
No, I don't really-
I just play Beethoven, really.
I'm not learning how to play.
And then I jam, too.
I know, but you're angering me,
because-
(Sona laughs)
That's enraging me how talented you are.
I'm sorry, it's just making me mad.
(Conan laughs)
I started in Earnest about six years ago.
So every night I would just start playing.
And, you know,
at that time it would take me a week
to get through one Sonata.
And now it's like two days.
I mean-
Sorry.
Two evenings-
Two hours to get through a Sonata.
No, I'm kind of blown away by that.
My relationship, I love playing music,
I love hacking around on guitar,
but it has never been intuitive for me.
I don't have that, which is,
and I've always really envied people
that have that ability to figure it out,
hear something,
and then it goes through their brain
and then they can make it happen
with their hands.
I need to actually-
I need to figure out
what is that shape
and I need to memorize it.
Hmm.
And that's how it works for me.
And it's why that is not my profession.
(Sona laughs)
But I'm really amazed, like,
I'm trying to think of you
as a kid and you're
listening to classical music,
but you're also, I'm sure,
listening to-
Heavy metal.
Heavy Metal.
And at what point do you say,
"I need to get my own guitar?"
Is that pretty early on?
Yeah.
It was last day of eighth grade.
There was a performance
by some other eighth grader,
eighth grade boys.
They went up and did
"Metal Health" by Quiet Riot
in front of the whole school.
And these were kids I knew
and they were just regular kids
and yet they were
playing these instruments
and it just sounded incredible.
It was just magic.
I was like,
"I should be able to do this."
And I got a guitar
and started a cover band,
did a bunch of metal songs,
and then moved out to
LA with my metal band,
and we thought we were
gonna make it like that,
but it didn't pan out and-
Yeah.
So whatever happened to you?
(everyone laughs)
You never made it in music
and then what happened?
That's how it sounded for a second.
Sorry.
Well, getting the job at Tower
really helped me.
Yeah.
I got exposed to all
different kinds of music.
Not just the latest, cool music,
but also going back to the 60s
and hearing The Beach Boys
and The Beatles,
and then talking to other employees there.
Some of them had been-
They were kind of lifers at Tower Records
and they're just so knowledgeable.
And-
What year is this now?
This is like early 90s?
Yeah. 90, 91.
Yeah.
And I met met the Weezer guys
through my coworkers there,
and we formed the band.
And the band is named-
It's a nickname that you had as a kid?
Yeah, that's what my dad called me
when I was very young.
I asked him, "Why'd you call me Weezer?"
And he said it was after the kid
in "The Little Rascals,"
there was a character named Weezer.
Oh, yeah.
Was there a Weezer?
There was like a froggy for a while,
then he probably grew too old
and they put in Weezer
or something like that.
They always needed a weird sounding kid
or something.
So I said, "Why him?"
And he said,
"Because he's the cool one."
Oh, that's cool.
Same reason I had a band called
"You Little Shit."
(everyone laughs)
Thank you, Dad.
We didn't really go anywhere.
It's also "My Favorite Little Rascal."
Yeah.
(Conan laughs)